enseigne de magasins d'alimentation
cherche un repreneur
la nouvelle a été annoncée la semaine
dernière par la direction aux
représentants des quelques centaines de
salariés employés par ecomax une
nouvelle qui confirme les grandes
difficultés du groupe lioen malgré la
vente il ya bientôt un an du centre
commercial océanis dans un marché en
pleine mutation
le mode de distribution que nous avons
connue depuis les années 90 avec un des
hypermarchés supermarchés est en train
de subir des transformations profondes
en france voit bien qu'à carrefour
je suis plaint des milliers d'emplois et
les gens qui nous est propre c'est le
fait que la martinique depuis 2007
régulièrement père 4000 habitants par an
le gâteau de la distribution sur d'être
ici et le nombre d'acteurs est toujours
la même et a tendance à s'accroître une
population martiniquaise en baisse avec
un pouvoir d'achat de plus en plus
restreint ces dernières années l'offre
discount s'est diversifiée en martinique
et les annonces d'arrivées de nouvelles
enseignes se sont multipliées avec pour
éternelles promesses la baisse des prix
dans un premier temps il y aura une
guerre des prix ce qui se passe ici en
martinique à une guerre des prix ont du
bon c'est formidable de la confiance et
puis dès ce bon monsieur bah ouais ça au
bout d'un moment il y à des cadavres sur
qui jonchent le sol
et puis ceux qui restent augmentent les
prix de son côté le groupe audio elle a
annoncé son choix de recentrer son
activité sur la commercialisation des
pièces d'automobiles